So good morning, everyone, it's
a great pleasure to introduce
Lian Gong, who's a PhD
student at UC Berkeley and
working with Koushik Sen,
so Koushik was actually my
colleague when I was in college,
small world.
So Liang has generally been
interested in program analysis,
doing analysis of properties for
checking correctness,
performance, security.
And his focus has been on
doing dynamic analysis for
JavaScript programs, [INAUDIBLE]
Microsoft more broadly two times
also Internet Google.
I saw the one that he did,
and it was not Microsoft,
actually it has been JS part of
Microsoft Software, and looking
forward to your talk Liang
>> Thank you for
the introduction, and
thank you everyone for coming,
instead of going to the top
front seats of the CEO [LAUGH].
And so today my talk is about
Dynamic Data Collection
Diagnostic for Improving
JavaScript Applications.
So this basically this gives
an overview of my research
the past seven years.
So in my during my PhD
in Berkeley I was mostly
focusing on dynamic analysis for
JavaScript.
And in Berkeley I was
[INAUDIBLE] working on a project
called Jalangi which was
initially started in some
research American and
it was also used in some
research in America.
And based on this project,
we also developed a number of
research for Dynamic Analysis.
And when I was interning
at Microsoft research,
I mostly worked with Mark, and
we were working on the a project
called Async-track, which is
also dynamic analysis framework.
It keeps track of the
interactions between the Node.js
application and
the underlying operation.
And that framework has been used
in the TraveCore engine for
time travel debugging.
And it's also been integrated
into Microsoft software
called No Glimpse which is a for
stack.
Node JS diagnostic tool and
based on that we further extend
our framework to be a sandbox
for Node JS based on which we
found about 300 security
vulnerabilities and
we projected it to some
security companies.
And about 120 of those security
vulnerabilities are considered
highly severe.
And in my second internship,
I actually worked with
the [INAUDIBLE] team,
working on memory visualization,
too, for [INAUDIBLE].
And we also shared the
[INAUDIBLE] with the [INAUDIBLE]
engineering team.
And before I start my,
so before my PhD,
I was also working on some
projects like applying machine
learning techniques to
software engineering problems.
So what we usually call
the repository so, in my
first part of my talk I'll first
talk about this Jalangi project.
So before I start,
let me first give you,
let me first introduce
the motivation of my research.
So why do we care
about JavaScript?
So a lot of people still thought
that JavaScript is still a toy
language, it has only
limited use in a browser.
Now these JavaScript have
already been increasingly
used in liking backend
service IT developments.
For all those companies
like Uber, LinkedIn,
PayPal, Bank of America,
Walmart, Netflix, they're
starting to use Node.js to build
their server side applications.
For all those desktop software
like Visual Studio code and
Slack are built on top of
Node.js and its variants.
This is another graph showing
the number of packages for
Node.js comparing the number of
packages for other languages.
So you can see over time so,
mpme essentially broken.
It's essentially exploding and
this is another slide
showing the download statistics
of npm packages over time.
So right now about every week
there are 2 billion downloads
of npm packages.
So it's actually growing
exponentially, but
unfortunately, JavaScript is
not well-designed language.
As many of you know, its first
version was designed and
implemented in merely 10 days.
And in such a rush,
not all design decisions
were well-thought, and there
are lots of problematic features
integrated into the language.
And using those bad features,
it can often lead to bugs,
performance issues or
even a security low
post in the language.
And JavaScript has to
be backward compatible,
so those language features
are still around.
And this is the joke on the
Internet saying that on the left
hand side there's a book
called JavaScript.
On the right hand side there is
a book called JavaScript:
The Good Parts and, yeah.
Comparing a thickness of these
two books you can quantify
the good parts of
the language and
the rest are what we
call the evil parts.
So on one hand you have
a language that's very popular,
but it has lots of awful parts.
So how do you deal
with this issue?
So industry there are a couple
of solutions either you program
your language in.
So usually you write a program
in other languages and
compile it into JavaScript.
So this is what
the TypeScript is doing or
Google's GW key
compiler is doing.
And there's another option is
that you provide better two
chain support for
JavaScript language.
So right now there are a couple
of tools that are widely adopted
in the industry for
JavaScript development.
So all of them are basically
linked tos, like GS team linked,
GS linked, [INAUDIBLE] S are
linked, and the closure linked.
I also interned as a Google
closure and polished my,
personally also developed
a couple of linked tos, for
closure linked.
But those tools are based
on static analysis and most
of them are actually based on
very primitive stack analysis,
where we should call
them syntactic analysis.
So they just check very simple
syntactic rules on JavaScript
and try to find some potential
errors in JavaScript code.
The limitation of static
analysis is pretty obvious.
They are trying to
approximate the wrong type
of behavior of a program.
And because of see limitations
of setting alias analysis or
other things,
it's very hard to do precise
step analysis of JavaScript.
And because of JavaScript
have lots of dynamic
features like prototypes, eval,
it's even harder to do stating
analysis for JavaScript.
So also often times those two
favorite precision of sounding
by suppressing warnings, and
so that's the challenge.
And we try to alleviate
this kind of problem
by using Dynamic Analysis.
And in the past four year
I've been working on about
two dynamic analyses
frameworks for JavaScript.
One's called Jalangi, the other
ones is called platform.
So for Jalangi, the idea is that
whenever you ask it a piece of
JavaScript code, Jalangi will
monitor the run-time events from
the JavaScript code.
And notify some basic run-time
events like reading a variable
or calling a function or setting
a property of an object and
stuff like that.
By overwriting those APIs
[INAUDIBLE] all sorts of
runtime events of JavaScripts
and then you can do
some kind of interesting dynamic
analysis on JavaScripts.
Async-Track and NodeSecurity or
send bugs focuses more on
the interactions between
the JavaScript code and
the underlying operating system.
So whenever there's
an interaction between Java code
and and
the underlying operating system.
This framework will actually
notify you some kind
of event like building a Node.js
module is being required,
or a synchronous system
API is being called.
Or a callback is
being registered, or
a callback is being logged and
stuff like that.
So I'll introduce the first
part which is Jalangi.
Jalangi is essentially a source
to source translation framework.
So for example, if we have
original JavaScript programs
which look like this which
assigns b's value to a, then
the simplified instruments the
code in Jalangi looks like this.
And it's preserving the original
semantics of the Java code.
Which means they will still
assign this to a, but
additionally, that's
two more callbacks.
So one callback corresponds to
the reading variable b another
callback corresponds to
the writing variable a.
So when you execute
this instrumented code,
you will not only assign
this value to a, but
it will additionally call these
two callback functions Yes?
>> So how much
[INAUDIBLE] would you say?
>> The average half is about
20 to 30 times slowdown.
But later,
I'm gonna show a demo, I'll show
it's actually a reasonable
slowdown for front end web page.
So, because usually,
in front of web page.
JavaScript is single
threaded application, right?
So as long as piece of Java code
is actually modeled in like 1
millisecond or
10 milliseconds then user can
kind of perceive the slow down.
So usually in the frontends
of JavaScript codes function
execution, it is actually
less than 10 milliseconds.
And then when software
instrumentation,
you can feel the slowdown,
but it's not just too slow.
So later on,
I can show a demo running on
the real world applications.
>> Are these technologies
intended be deployed on
an offline manner in some test
phase, or actually in online?
>> Yeah, it's only meant to
be deployed for in house like
browser testing and heavyweight
dynamic analysis, not for
the production service side
involvement deployments.
So after overriding
those primitives,
you can do all sorts of
interesting dynamic analysis.
And Jalangi handles all kinds
of runtime events in JavaScript.
Like creating a literal,
a read variable,
putting a field to an object,
or calling a function,
entering branch, unit operation,
binary operation, etc., etc.
And because the JavaScript is
a kind of weird languages,
there are lots of weird texts
and semantics, as there
are a lot of corner pieces that
we learnt in a hard way so
we spent a lot of time working
on the engineering part of this
project to make it work on
real world applications.
And so first let me give
you a demo of the Jalangi.
So we have online demo
of Jalangi and so this
webpage gives you a live demo
for what Jalangi looks like.
And I can create the statements,
the signs to be.
On this panel,
it will likely show
the instrument codes right here.
And you can even see more, but
I mean is so, for example,
I have a program, and here is
the instrument to the program.
And over here,
it shows the Jalangi API, right?
I can override all kinds of,
Sorry, so I can override all
kinds of runtime events such as
putting field to an object,
creating literal.
By overriding those functions,
you can receive all kinds of
runtime variables or
values or events.
Like for example,
binary operation and
inside this function, you will
receive events such as what's
the type of that
binary operation?
What's the left operant?
What's the right operant?
And what's the result?
And you can even return
different results,
kind of modifies the behavior
of the JavaScript program during
the execution.
And yeah, and if your runtime
will show that there is null
which is not a number
generates and
that usually corresponds to like
anomaly during the execution in
the JavaScript program.
Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE] what
you instrument or-
>> Yeah,
I'll introduce that part
a little bit later.
Because we've done dynamic loss
research based on these two and
we use it to check issues and
performance issues
in JavaScript code.
>> So how do you library you
actually interpret the source as
well, of both libraries?
>> So for libraries,
we also instrument that as well.
So anything's that running in
the browser, we instrument that.
But we also selectively
not instrument that,
that actually requires
additional engineering work.
So, when I was in Berkeley,
I also did another work to
put Jalangi on the backend to
frontend because Jalangi was
originally design for
running on Node.js.
And we also wanted
the dynamic loss for
JavaScript in the frontend
webpage as well.
But in the frontend of
JavaScript execution model,
it's still a little bit more
complicated than Node.js because
in the frontend, there's a lot
of different ways that you can
trigger a piece of JavaScript
code in the browser.
Because you can incorporate
a piece of JavaScript code,
adjusting the html file.
Or even import a piece
of JavaScript code from
external fine.
Or even dynamically request a
piece of JavaScript code through
the Ajax.
Or even dynamically generate
a piece of JavaScript code and
insert it to backend
into webpage.
So we experiment with different
kinds of implementation and
we finalized our prototype
to handle all those kinds of
scenarios.
So our implementation
works like web proxy.
We'll monitor all the request
that's sent out from my
computer.
And if the response contains
any piece of JavaScript code,
it will be intercepted and
instrumentated.
So all JavaScript codes before
they reach the browser,
they are already
instrumented by Jalangi.
I'll give you a front-end demo
of what Jalangi looks like.
So here, I'll start my proxy.
Okay.
And now, I'm going to
start loading a webpage
using web geo to show
a stunning visual effects of
water in the web page,
yeah, that's right.
So this web page is
fully instrumented,
I can show you the source codes.
So for example, if I click on
this one as you can see here,
all these codes
are already instrumented.
These [INAUDIBLE] and
stuff like that are all hoax
instrumented by Jalangi.
And to answer your question,
as you can see,
this is the instrument
webpage looks like.
So the slow down actually also
depends on the dynamic analysis
of codes that you're
going to write.
Fore example, here I'm going to
instrument all of the reading
variable operations in
the front-end of the web page.
So I just create this callback
function saying .read = iid
which means the ID of the soft
location, name of the variable,
value of the variable,
there are other arguments, but
I just don't care.
So and because JavaScript's
a dynamic language,
I can just ignore them.
And if I just print all variable
names that are read by the web
application, then they'll
be extremely slow so
I just want to do some sampling.
Say every 1000 operations,
I'll just print the name of
the variable that's being read.
And if I do that,
as you can see,
it's printing the variable name.
And I can even replace the hoops
at runtime, so that you will
have a much higher sampling
rates like every 100 operations.
And as you can see here,
it's becoming much slower and
I can remove
the hoops at runtime.
So as you can see here, stop
printing the variable names and
it is becoming faster again.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Because of IO,
just printing the value and
name?
>> Yes, and also for
very variable operations, so or
very variable reading operation,
you are additionally
calling a function,
a callback function that's also
causing some of the slow down.
>> But that's regardless whether
you print every 1000 variable or you-
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Right, right.
>> So, so-
>> This IO is the difference
[INAUDIBLE]-
>> Right, right.
In this example,
IO is the bottle neck.
>> That's surprising
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Okay, sorry.
So based on this drawing here,
we actually did
a number of research.
One of these researchers
that we won't use is
in the frontal web page.
So we developed this tool called
feelings which is a tool for
dynamically checking bad
coding practice in JavaScript.
So, because JavaScript is not
a well designed language,
there are a lot of awful
parts in the language.
And people in the software
industry have learned a thing
over time called
coding practice, so
which are essentially
a set of informal
rules that people have
learned over time.
And if you follow those rules,
you can generally improve
the quality of your software.
So by better quality,
I mean fewer bugs,
or better performance, or
better maintaining ability, or
even fewer security
vulnerabilities in your code.
And to give you
a concrete example for
what coding practice looks like
in JavaScript so let me ask you
to take a look at this small
chunk of code and think about
what would be the final value
of the sum after executing.
Single jobs for code.
So I ask this question
to all of the people,
including some of the developers
in Microsoft and Google and
so far nobody has given
me a 100% correct answer.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> No.
So three is actually one of
the wrong answers that I got
frequently.
A lot of people that that
going over array elements.
So default evaluation would be
66, but unfortunately going over
arrays is rating over property
names inside an object.
So here because
[INAUDIBLE] array,
then it's actually
[INAUDIBLE] axis.
Some people call this
[INAUDIBLE] are of
the [INAUDIBLE] string.
So [INAUDIBLE] axis
to string values.
Well for the final value
should be 0, 0, 1,
2 just the short answer.
Another issue is that there
is some cross-browser issues.
There are some earlier
versions of some browsers, it
not going over very well so each
over all the building system
function names Insights in array
objects, so like index off of
two string walls so we can
calculate to the final result.
And even for browsers like
Firefox or Chrome, if you
add additional properties to the
prototype object of that array,
those additional property names
will also be iterated over and
concatenated to
the final string.
So the correct way is easier
to use a conventional for
loop or use building functions
to iterate over array elements.
So if you use
for..in over array. Array.
It's likely that you will
misunderstand the semantics
of the codes and
you are likely to
introduce into a code.
And the people when they were
factoring the codes they may
misunderstand your codes and
they may introduce sparks.
And also because using for
in over arrays matches slower
than the following two ways.
So the conclusion
is avoid using for
in over arrays in JavaScript
whenever possible.
If you want to statically
detect this kind of bad coding
practice it's very hard because
you have to determine whether or
not this obj is an array or not.
But that's generally a very
hard problem for JavaScript.
Because JavaScript's a very
dynamic language, and typing
inferences is also very hard
without the type annotations.
But in Jalangi, it's very easy.
All you have to do is that,
first let Jalangi identify all
the for in Program constructs
in your program and
whenever you found the falling
over rate, it just writes
a dynamic system monitor of the
values as flowing into this lot,
and if this obj add run
time is in arrays then
you are doing falling
over array, that's.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
LIke it's object, array,
object, array, those kinds of
>> Yeah in that case it's
still doing [INAUDIBLE] right
because sometimes it's doing
[INAUDIBLE] and the result
becomes unpredictable.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah
it will issue a soft warning.
So we looked at JavaScript.
>> How do you actually
program this?
So do you have some kind
of declarative framework to
explain these probabilities, or
do you have go and
[INAUDIBLE] application?
>> Right, so
in my demo right here,
so provides a set of APIs
that it can override, and
one of the APIs is actually
a for loop, and then you can
detect whether or not
>> It's for reconstructs and
if it is you can just
check at wrong time and
see if that operating
section an array or not.
>> I was just wondering
if you have [INAUDIBLE]
instrumented to
your cellphone or
have you also thought of what
you wanted a [INAUDIBLE] field
[INAUDIBLE] specify this
>> So far we don't
have a way for you to declare
which part of the program
belongs to instrument and
which parts do not.
So currently what we do is
we just instruments array,
basic programming construct.
And at wrong time you can
chose to override these
functions or not.
So at runtime if you don't
override those functions then
there will be no call
back being invoked.
Otherwise there will be
a call back invoked.
That's definitely one away
to lower down the overhand
of the [INAUDIBLE].
So in our DLint project,
we analyzed JavaScript language,
and we formalized about 28 code
smell runtime patterns, and
we right on 200 of the world's
most popular websites, and we
found about 19 clear bugs on the
world's most popular websites.
>> Best of the?
So, so far we just randomly
loads the page on those websites
without actually doing more
very specifics, the advanced,
the dynamic or,
testing generation to actually
trigger more actions
things of our page.
>> [INAUDIBLE] the rent
time patterns.
They are code patterns, right?
They are not static or
dynamic they are code patterns.
What do you mean by
[INAUDIBLE] pattern
>> So by real time patterns this
means that it's like if
wrong time events exists
its like a predicate of what
we should do or what we should
check is something like that and
>> Where if you have like static
usually you have checkers that
also condition on what your,
if the that do this, so
the monitor that you kind of do
is kind of, like for instance,
we have, not for JavaScript, but
internally, 10 plus years ago,
I mean with the interactive
language of specification, and
you can either check them
>> Or you can drag them
as a runtime switch and
do it at runtime right?
So, So I don't know if there is
something really specific that
you can only do at runtime, or.
Yes, so
here are all the patents that,
so most of these patents can
only be detected medically.
If you wanted to be
detected statically
the job description
is very Hard.
>> It is hard yet
you said [INAUDIBLE] the
property specification itself we
call variant itself.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Is the same whether
you do it statically or
dynamically, that
was my question.
>> Yes right.
Yes so here is the example
of our Formalize the runtime
pattern, and so
I won't jump into more details
here because we
have limited time.
And so here's one also we found
three years ago in Hilton's
websites.
It shows that one day as
the starting price they
set undefined dollars.
Which is literally
an exceptional price.
And so DLint can pinpoint
the exact location where this
undefined was
concatenated to this $.
And here's another example
on IKEA's web page.
It shows that for some items,
last year's price
is not a number.
And we also did some empirical
study and tried to compare our
dynamic lint with the existing
static lint tool.
And so here is the spectrum.
It actually consists
of hundreds of lines,
and each line shows
the percentages of
warnings detected by each
tool on the specific website.
For example, the green part
shows the percentage of
warnings detected by the JSHint
uniquely and the yellow part
means the percentage of
warning detected by uniquely.
And black part shows the
detected commonly by both two.
And as you can see here for
some websites you can use one
link to detect most of the.
issues, but for most websites,
you better use them together.
Our conclusion is that
static link tos and
dynamic link tos
complement each other.
>> I think [INAUDIBLE] actually
discovered all the errors, but
it discovered more [INAUDIBLE]
>> Static choose,
it won't detect all of the
>> Warnings.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> There's another issue because on
[Laughter]
>> There may be some [INAUDIBLE]
issues with the steady
[INAUDIBLE],
like there are some other issues
>> Warnings like falling
over rays.
So static too cannot detect
these kind of issues.
So they just won't
flag status or
warning because saying
usually favor precision over.
And they just don't
show that warning.
And in that case,
a dynamic link too can actually
detect that kind of issue.
Okay So
another problems that we look at
is the performance of JavaScript
because JavaScript uses
a Just-in-time compiler which it
means Just-in-time compilation.
It's a took a money show in
the printer and the compiler so
what he does, he starts
off with interpreter and
then based off of some profiling
information he collects and
makes some aggressive
assumptions and then compiles
the function some hard function
into making assembly codes.
The good things that
it's greatly improves
the code of gashing codes, but
the bad part is that Is make
the performance of JavaScript
codes very unpredictable.
And we investigated
this kind of issue and
we proposed the term called
JIT-unfriendly code.
Which means the piece of
the JavaScript codes that's very
hard for the JIT engines
to profit for optimization.
So the key idea is,
In JavaScript you
can write code in many ways
to achieve the same goal.
However if you write your
code in some way, it may be
harder for the JIT engine to
optimize some part of the code.
So but if you write
it in another way it
may be a lot faster.
And here I'll give
you one example.
Suppose that you initialize
an empty array and
you want to insert 10,000 values
inside of that array
with value I as index I.
There are two ways you can do
this you can easily initialize
the array from higher
index to lower index.
Or you can initialize
the array from lower index to
higher index.
And this way is about 10
times slower than this way.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Sorry?
>> How do you determine
>> Yeah,
I'll cover last part
a little bit later, but
let me first explain
what's going on here.
So if you unload the loop
becomes a little bit
more obvious.
>> Because what happens is that
at first, so what happens is
that if you initialize the array
from higher index to lower index
at first you have just
created an empty array.
So all of a sudden you start
assigning values at a very high
index, then you start assigning
values to the lower index.
So the first half
of the iteration
the JIT engine suddenly creates
A very sparse array, therefore
in order to save memory
the JIT engine will actually
convert the array to a hash
table inside the JIT engine.
And later on when things that
you are actually creating in non
sparse array will actually
convert that sparse array into
a contiguous memory space.
So that goes back ad forth and
that actually
wastes a long time.
And also accessing a hash table
is much slower than accessing
a native array.
And so we investigate some
of the in JavaScripts,
and based on we developed
which is a profiling for
detecting JIT-unfriendly
coding JavaScript.
So what essentially does,
it receives random
events from And this
independently simulates what's
going on inside the jet engine.
For example,
here you you're creating
rate you're accessing
very frequently.
Issue a warning.
How are you
Inefficient access patterns
happens in this location.
So based on our JitProf tool we
actually experimented on some
benchmarks like [INAUDIBLE]
benchmark or some spider
benchmark and we found a lot of
Jit-unfriendly code patterns in
those benchmarks as well, and
by fixing those Jit-unfriendly
code patterns, usually just by
swapping two lines of code or
just modifying one line of
code in the Bench mark,
we can improve the performance
by 1% to 26% and
those improvements
are statistically significant.
So here's another
one JIT-unfriendly
code patterns that we found
in real world program.
So here we have a tree
Data structure.
So what happens is,
in the tree data structures,
there are about 10s of
thousands of nodes, and for
each node, they are constructed
by this constructor function.
However, based on different
conditions, the constructor may
initialize the node processing
in different order.
Like in this then branch, and
we'll first initialize this left
property and then we'll
initialize this right property.
This else branches,
their orders are reversed.
And if we just swap these
two lines of codes, and
we get 15% performance
improvement on Chrome, and
about 3.5% performance
improvement on Firefox.
So it's essentially related to a
thing called inline caching and
hidden costs [INAUDIBLE] engine.
So I won't expand more technical
details here because this part
itself can be expanded
to like a one hour talk.
And actually about two months
ago the travel core team had
also had an internal
talk about this part.
Any travel core is hidden
class is called a types or
stuff like that and
it's also called maps or
hidden classes in bay's engine.
So what's happening here is the
original codes or the original
constructor may create objects
of two different kinds of memory
layouts in memory like if it
enters this stembranch then
this is what the object will
look like inside the memory.
the left proxy will have lower
offsets and the right proxy will
have higher offsets and we enter
this off branch this proxy will
have a higher offsets while this
left Will have a lower offset,
and this left property
will have a higher offset.
And when all those objects
flow like to one position and
we are trying to retrieve
the left property from the node
Object, the can
maybe get confused,
because the probably can be
using it a lower offset, or
in a higher offsets of the
engine cannot do some aggressive
assumption assuming that
always in the fixed location.
Therefore, every time we need to
retrieve the object always have
to do to find it's property's
location inside of the object
And if we swap these two lines
of codes each engine can just
replace, aggressively replace
this operational with like
nodes, with something like
this in the JIT engine.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
One is
to formalize what
the pattern is and
then to find the instances of
this pattern in a [INAUDIBLE]. Yep.
>> So who finalizes the pattern?
So this is something that
a developer has to think about
manually first, or
can you even discovery these
patterns automatically?
>> No we can't discovery
those patterns automatically.
What we did is we investigate
into most of the major jet
engines and
tried to summarize some of
the friendly co-patterns
in those Engine sends, and
we just formalize them by
ourselves, as incorporating to
the JavaScript engine, but
there is some way to do that.
For example, in Mozilla,
an actually Mozilla has its
own coach, which is almost doing
the same as what we did, but
we did it first because entire
webpage They also show as well.
So what JIT Coach is
essentially doing is,
because Mozilla has its own
Firefox SpiderMonkey engine,
what they do is try to see
if there is any deoptimization
in their JIT engine.
And then they try to see
are those [INAUDIBLE] frequently
then they may give some
actionable suggestions for
the developer like how to like
modify the code a little bit
like in the previous example you
can just make the constructure
to create objects in a more
consistent Formats or
more consistent layouts and
hopefully you can improve
the of your program.
And yes, so
this is one way to do that.
Like you can deeper
into the engine and
see where is
the optimization happens.
And then the optimization
operation
[INAUDIBLE]
Some optimizations
Kind of.
>> Yeah for the hidden class and
the inline caching I think
all engine is doing that
kind of optimization and
that's actually how to cross
all engines and I think for
the Sparse array, the V Engine,
the Travel Core, and
also the Spider Monkey engine
are also doing the same thing.
Yeah so in our.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Got
a common pattern
of all engines
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yes.
>> Overall how many optimization
[INAUDIBLE] that are in modern
JIT engines for
JavaScript compared to let's say
the optimization that are in
a C compiler for instance.
It's basically is it the same
complexity or are they simpler?
Or are they more complex?
So I think the atomization
engine is very different from
the ahead-of-time optimization
because in the compilation
happens at runtime, so
what are trying to do is save,
to reduce the compiling
time as much as possible.
So they will actually not use
some of the advanced static
and or compile.
>> The that you've shown on the
previous slide, which if course
fits on one slide
>> May not be that easy.
But maybe there is some
[INAUDIBLE] that has already
implemented 20 years ago,
in let's say JCC that recognizes
pattern and automatically
kind of fix the problem.
And then this is just basically
the JavaScript world catching up
with step by step with something
trying to [INAUDIBLE].
Or not this is basically
something you put in.
Wrote this program C a high
immunization whatever,
and this still is an open
problem or it's a problem that's
been solved 20 years ago and
you're catching up [INAUDIBLE].
>> Right group question so in
>> In
statically typed language
this issue shouldn't exist,
because for each one of
the objects, they're [INAUDIBLE]
structure is already
determined before execution.
So the compiler just
grab class structure
without actually dynamically
look up the property's location.
They can just look up the, Class
structure of that object is then
>> You have [INAUDIBLE] typing.
You can cast [INAUDIBLE].
Simulate perhaps
accurately [INAUDIBLE]
>> [INAUDIBLE] You don't know
what the shape of the object
>> Yes because you know that
different if conditions whereas
in static languages you already
have this class node define,
it has all other features.
>> But so if you were to compare
basically the amount of code
let's say that deal with
all these optimization,
is it like comparable to what
let's say a modern statistic
comparator does with
>> All the optimization for
a statically typed language,
or is it an more or less,
you see what I mean?
So it's kind of.
>> So I honestly, I don't know
how many optimization are there
in the static-
>> There are lots of optimizations
>> Yeah.
>> Complex.
>> It's more like a hundred or
a thousand, give me a number.
>> [LAUGH] So I think knows.
>> Simple question, right?
So how many are there
to optimize or
something All the classical
organizations are [INAUDIBLE]
and copy probe and
things like that.
There are also optimizations
that are purely based on
the dying feature.
Optimizing [INAUDIBLE]
cashing so
kind of things that
are different i nature.
We can't really compare
>> This
is very complex
>> This is complex because you
don't know anything
that you can change for
the right object on runtime,
and then you don't know
the [INAUDIBLE] property runtime
>> ok,
thank you
>> In the next part of my presentation
>> Briefly
summarize some of the projects
I did in Microsoft research.
And so, this project is
called Async-Track and
I've already given a very
detailed talk about these parts.
In my end-of-internship
talk two years ago.
And you can actually
search node.js, or
you could just search
my name on resnet.
You'll be able to see more
technical details about
the project.
But to summarize, back in
2006 16 we developed a true.
We started off with a project
that tries to to keep track of.
So what happens is something.
NodeJS, there are lots of
asynchronous operations.
You can register a callback.
And after the operating system
has done something then you
call the callback to notify user
the event has been completed.
But the problem is when
the callback is being evoked,
the functions in the registers
the callback has
Popped out from the stack trace.
So there is no way for
you to debug or
trace back to the location where
that call back was registered.
So we tried to implement
the instrumentation frame was it
keeps track of this Node.js.
And so that framework has been
integrated into Glimpse for
NodeJS, which
a diagnostic tool for
NodeJS developed by Microsoft.
And because initially,
we just keep track of all
asynchronous events in NodeJS.
Then we just go a little bit
further to keep track of all
synchrony events in node.js.
So right now that means we can
keep track of all interaction
between the node.js
application and
the underlying operating system.
So that means we have a sandbox,
and we extend the sandbox for
node.js security research.
And we found a box behind
a security wall ability and
this was the title of my talk
two years ago, it's called
'Tracing and Understanding
Async Calls in Node.js'.
So this is the overview of
the Node.js architecture, and
on the top levels there is
Node.js application, and
Node.JS application always needs
to use some of the underlying
library provides by the Node.JS
runtime so, for example,
if you want to read
the file system,
you always have to, first
require a file system package.
The file system packaging
contains some building system
functions, that allow you to
have access to the underlying
operating system's file system.
And there are many other
like packages like that.
And those standard library
functions are essentially
just the JavaScript wrapper
of the underlying operating
system call.
And they are translated through
this Node.JS binding layer,
which translates to
JavaScript call to C ++ call.
Then, under that,
you have the JavaScript engine,
you can have V8 or ChakaraCore,
Event Loop, Threat Pool, or
Sync & Async I/O provided
by the operating system.
So what we did is, we hijack all
of the communication between
the Node.js application and the
underlying JavaScript engine.
By modifying this are jobs the
standard library of the bonding
layer, and
also do dynamic implementation.
So after hijacking all the
communication between the upper
approaches patient and
underlying open system, we can
intercepts those system costs,
and enforce some
security policies.
And based on that,
we can dynamically check some
of the security issues in OGS.
And we also verify that,
as the node binding layer,
that all of the communication
are essentially are actually
being hijacked by our
instantiation code.
So the key idea of this
instrumentation, is a little bit
different from the source
to source transpolation.
So the problem is that,
in JavaScript or
in Node.js, once you have a
system call, the system call can
return an object that contains
in another system call.
And that system call,
can have an asynchronous
function that takes a callback.
And whenever callback
is being invoked,
it may pass in other objects
with other system calls.
So, it's not just
simply wrapping all of
the building APIs.
Because if that API returns an
object that contains other APIs,
then that may be missed.
So our approach is that,
we implement our instrumentation
like a virus in the memory
space of the JavaScript code.
So whenever there is JavaScript
library objects is being
required, it's first being
hijacked and being infected or
wrapped by our
instrumentation framework.
Then, when that infected system
API, further return here,
other objects, that's also
being recursively infected, or
wrapped, by our code.
So in that case,
all of the code that's been
descended, that's the children
of the computing system objects
are all wrapped recursively.
And when the JavaScript
code tries to use those,
in fact the objects or
functions to make a system call,
then they would be monitored
by instrumentation code.
So that's a key idea.
But there are also other tricks,
and also other things that we
need to handle like how to
handle the asynchronous calls,
and how to handle the call back.
And those part I won't cover in
more details here because they
are already covered in the talk.
So our instrumentation framework
provides these kind of APIs
a callback is being registered,
a callback is being invoked,
a synchronous system
call is being called.
What's their runtime value,
what's their arguments,
what's their registration
context, and
what's their callback invocation
context, and stuff like that.
And over writing those
callbacks you can do a lot of
other interesting stuff.
So one we thing look at is
the security issue in Node JS.
So currently there
are about over
500,000 npm packages right now,
and
they're still increasing
very rapidly.
NPM doesn't actually enforce
any security checking, or
manual inspection, or
manual review process,
so anyone can just publish
a malware in NPM, and
anyone can download
it very easily.
So There are currently
two companies.
There are maybe other companies,
but
there are two major companies.
One of these is called Node
Security Platform, another one
is called Snyk.io, that are
dedicated to Node.js Security.
What they are doing is that they
have a team of security experts,
You manually inspect
the MPM packages, and
we also collect all kinds of
vulnerability reports on gethub,
and we collect
the vulnerabilities and
compile them into
their database.
And then they will make it
to check the meta file of
the MPM package and
say If a package's dependencies,
and its dependencies'
dependencies,
are any vulnerable packages
in their database.
By just matching the packaging
name and their version.
But we think this
approach is not scalable.
And so,
we use our node send box to
Dynamically check about
330,000 npm packages.
And we found about 292
security vulnerabilities and
we're still in the process of
reporting those vulnerabilities
to those companies and so far we
have already 150 confirmed and
the 120 are considered
highly severe.
Those two companies collectively
have about 600 security
vulnerabilities.
So a quarter of their
vulnerabilities
are recorded by us.
>> Do you know how
they were reported?
Who reported them?
>> There are many
different ways to report.
The easier is just to actively
look up security log lists
on GitHub's, and
they just the composite into
their database by themselves or
there are other people like me
who report it to them as well.
>> So like if you reported they
have at fifty and they have six
hundred before but this is like
one person put like six hundred
or it's like a collage
collection of things that you-
>> Yeah a large collection
of things.
>> Did you
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah,
so they're essentially
using crowdsourcing to
find security vulnerabilities.
>> System depends on [INAUDIBLE]
he's right because that's how
they get a secret assessment.
>> Yeah.
>> They have a very small base.
If you have 500,000 stuff and
you have only 600 or 750 now.
>> So-
>> Why does that make sense?
>> So in NPM,
it works like this.
First example,
if you have NPM packages,
it may depend on
other 20 packages.
Those other 20 packages
may recursively depend on
hundreds of other packages.
So it's actually called
dependency hell.
When you write a package,
I think someone did an
investigation about say if you
implement some
functionalities of publish or
mpm, only 5% of the code is
written by that developer.
Other 95% is coming from those
dependencies, and because of
this dependency hell, any
package may accidentally require
any other package developed by
the By some malicious users or
other people who are not very
helpful with their codes.
They may actually introduce
vulnerable teams
into their code.
So it's actually a kind of
a serious issue in NPM.
This is one of the malicious
packages that we found if you
just installed the NPM package
you will change your background
of your computer into
A naked David Hasselhoff.
And another example for
security vulnerabilities
is the Directory Traversal.
So we found about 220
packages having this issue so
Directory Traversal means that
Whenever Apache tries to set up
the http server or,
in other words, a server, and
when the client tries to request
the file from the server.
If the outreach is not very
careful, he or she may just
concatenate the requested URL
with the basdir, then just read
the file and stream it out
to the remote clients.
That's vulnerable to
this kind of attack,
because attacker can
just use this URL like
../../ to request any file or
size of the working directory.
And there are lots of other
variants of this kind
of attacking URL, so
it's a little bit hard to defend
against this kind of things.
And even worse,
all of these directory traversal
vulnerabilities can be further
exploited to perform
denial-of-service attack.
Or just requesting this
/dev/zero file, which is a Linux
virtual files that provides
unlimited strings with zeros.
And if you read that
file on the server,
then it would just lead to
the consumption of all memory.
Or leads to a consumption
of the network bandwidth,
which is essentially causing
a denial-of-service attack.
>> [INAUDIBLE] fixing the work.
Does your tool able to find
that kind of problems?
>> So what do you mean by hash?
>> So basically, they used
to have a constant seed for
initializing the hash tables and
somebody can just send
multiple inquiries that
will go into the same key.
That will map to same key
in the hash table, and
you have a long chain.
And it could be like
denial-of-service attack.
>> I see, I see.
>> Does this tool able to
find those kind of scenarios?
That was more like
very specific but
it was through the node
app that was exposed.
They patched it last Monday,
I guess.
>> So I'm not sure if detecting
that kind of vulnerability can
be manifested as
a runtime pattern between
the Node.js application and
the underlying operating system.
It can be formalized as just
a single pattern of the system
call from the Node general
application to the online
operating systems and it can be
detected by this kind of tool.
There are many other interesting
malicious packages of
security vulnerabilities
that we found in the NPM.
We also found a worm in NPM, so
what it happens is that if
you install the package,
it will self-replicate and
publish itself on the NPM again.
And we also have some pranked
NPM packages like Rockstar.
What happens is that if you
install that package, it will
use the victim's NPM account
to give itself a start on NPM.
So we also found some packages,
once you install the package,
it will override some of the
other packages on your computer.
We also found some packages that
are having some privacy issues.
Like every time we
install that package,
it will collect some of your
data on your computer and send
it to Google analytics or send
it to its own private server.
And for some package,
every time we use it,
it will collect your
machine's information and
send it to a remote private
server and stuff like that.
Yeah, we reported our overall
vulnerabilities to Snyk IO.
They send me a card and then we
report another bunch of them.
They send me another card and
t-shirt.
And this instrumentation
framework also enables other
kinds of applications.
For example, because it can keep
track of asynchronous events in
Node.js, you can
actually visualize them.
And it will help debugging, it
will help program understanding,
and stuff like that.
It's also helping TTD for better
time travel and debugging.
Because when you're in
a callback function,
in the time traveling debugger,
often times you want to jump
back to the position where
the callbacker was registered.
Instead of jumping back to the
exact functions that were being
executed before that callback
function was being executed.
And it can also be used to
detect security issues, or this.
So maybe you can also implement
a container inside Node.js
because you are essentially
hijacking all the interactions
between Node.js and
the underlying operating system.
You can implement some sort
of containerization just for
Node.js.
Those are just a few examples.
For the last part
of my presentation,
I actually want to focus
a little bit more on the project
that I've been working on
before I started my PhD.
So I was working on applying
machine-learning techniques to
some of the software
engineering problems,
specifically like
fault localization,
defect prediction,
predicting bug fixing time.
So, but in summary,
what essentially I was doing is
actually either
cleaning the data for
defect prediction or
for fault localization,
each one as a problem is
like a prediction problem.
And so what we did is that
you can use measure and
eliminate the effect of noisy
data and give back prediction.
Because often times when we
collect some data from the soft
engineering projects, there may,
because humans make many
mistakes all the time, and
the collected data may be noisy.
And we measure the effectiveness
of those, the native effect
of those noises in those data
sets, to the prediction result.
And we also worked on
some projects that
tries to eliminate some noisy
data in those data sets and
try to improve
the prediction accuracy.
We also tried to reduce
the redundancy in training data
while still preserving
the prediction accuracy, and
stuff like that.
And because we worked on this
project a little bit earlier,
back in 2011 and 12, so
we actually did a lot of
the feature engineering work and
incorporating domain
specific knowledge
into the training data.
It's essentially adding more
information into the prediction
models so that it can have
better prediction results, or
even changing
the machine-learning process.
Originally, it's doing
batch processing, and
then we incorporated some
simple feedback to the loop so
that they can incorporate
more information for
better prediction.
However, I actually don't
want to focus on those parts,
because there are actually some
of the more important lessons
that I've learned from doing
this kind of research.
So to show you one example,
this is the technical
fault localization.
So what this is trying to do is,
if you have a program and
it contains some bugs.
And you have a set
of test cases, and
when we run the program on
the set of test cases, some of
the test cases will pass, some
of the test cases will fail.
And so the question is can
you automatically learn or
can you automatically
do something for
instance find out the bug
locations in that program.
So to the approaches that we
worked on is called statistic
bug localization.
It's actually, first they're
collecting the profiling
information, like coverage
information for each one of
the statement, in each test
coverage, in each test cases.
Then we also gather the test
outcome as a letter,
put it right here.
And then we use some techniques
to try to predict, or infer,
the probable bug location
inside the program.
And actually back in 2009,
people in that
research area already started
using [INAUDIBLE] to predict so
where is the bug,
is probably inside the program.
So the first use of to, based
on this coverage information and
this letter,
which is pass the test or
fail to try to predict
the testing outcome.
And when they learn
that works and
they just do some
feature selection and
see which statements are the
most influential factor to make
the predictor predict that
this output is fail or pass.
Yes?
>> Is it an assumption that
there is only one bug?
>> No, there are two different
kinds of prediction techniques.
One is called single bug.
Bug localization and
another one just assumes there
are multiple bugs in the code.
>> And where does that
training data come from for
training these systems?
So you have a repository of bug
fixes in the past that you had?
>> No, no bug fixes.
So let me see.
So in that example
that I just mentioned,
the training data, so
it just looks like this.
Each instance is
the current information and
each labor of that instance
is just the test outcome.
And then, they just ask
the machine learning detector to
first predict accurately
the test outcome.
Then it tries to take a look at
the machine learning model and
try to find out which
statement or which feature
is the most influential effect
leading to make such a predictor
to believe that this should
be a failed test case.
Yeah, so but
a lot of people have take a look
at a lot of different kinds of
machine learning techniques.
They also even use decision
tree, which is even easier for
you to find out which line of
code is most influential for
predicting and test the outcome. Yes?
>> So this side [INAUDIBLE].
So you mention that though you
can look at the model to see
which part of the model is
making that prediction that
the test case will pass or fail.
But how would you do this for
let's say neural networks where
the models might be quite
intricate, maybe not as simple
as the [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah I think in that paper
they have some heuristics, too,
but I don't remember actually
the technical details because we
actually don't work on
that kind of technique.
Because later on I
will actually show you
that kind of machine learning
techniques is not very
accurate in this
kind of problem.
And because,
a more simple statistic model is
actually more effective for
this kind of approach.
But later on,
I'll actually tell you that
even this kind of approach
is not practical.
And I'll show you some of the
lessons I learned why this kind
of approach is not actually
practical for real world usage.
So people have
learned over time,
so this is actually called a
spectrum-based bug localization.
I think it was a quite hot
research area 10 years ago, and
I think more than 100 papers
are publishing software sharing
conferences for
that research area.
And so, different people propose
different kinds of techniques
to tackle the suspicious core
of a statement in the program.
And they try to
rank the statements
based on their suspiciousness
and then they just
expect the developer to inspect
the buggy location one by one.
And hopefully this technique
can help them find out
the bug location.
So one of the most effective
techniques is actually
the simplest one.
So the key idea is that
they use this formula, for
each one of the statements, to
calculate this suspicious score,
independently.
So this formula is
actually quite easy.
On the numerator, it's just
the counted number of failure
traces that are covering
that current statement.
While on the denominator,
it's just the number of failing
traces and the number of
which traces are covering S.
So the basic intuition
is that if a statement
is covered more in failing test
cases while covered less in
passing test cases, then it's
more likely to contain the bug.
Yes, so
it's a very simple idea right?
And usually on some
small benchmarks, or
even on some medium programs
it often ranks the actual bug
location, I think the top
1% of the rank list,
with respect to all of these
statements in the program.
And I also have a demo for that.
It's actually based
on Jalangi as well.
So because our Jalangi is
instantiation framework you can
do a lot of things
based on that, so
I just implemented them
in Jalangi as well.
And this is actually a simple
application for MOOC.
Like students can send me
some buggy solutions and
the instructor can upload
the reference implementation.
Then our system can just
randomly generate a bunch of
test cases and then runs on the
referencing implementation and
gets the corrected test outcome.
Then we just run those
test cases on the buggy
implementation, and then we
also get the test outcome.
And then we just compare their
test outcome to decide whether
or not test case is passing or
failing.
And then based on
that simple formula,
we can calculate
the possible bug location.
For example, if I just run, then
you will flag all the potential
bug locations in the codes.
And if it's more
likely to be a bug,
then you'll have a darker
background color.
So here it shows that this is a
bug, it's actually a seeded bug.
And if I just fix it and
I run again,
then it will show no more
failing test cases and
every statement is
considered clean.
>> So you use a technique that
you had published a long time
ago for this or?
>> It's actually not
the techniques that I published
a long time ago, but
our technique was trying to
improve this kind of technique.
So this kind of ranking
technique, say,
is actually based on
very ancient statistical
back-localization technique.
It just subs a very simple
formula that I showed
right here.
>> Well hang on a second, so
what is your contribution here?
>> So
our contribution here is, so
one project that we did is
try to reduce the number of
trainings that are needed by
this kind of prediction model,
while still preserving
its accuracy.
So in other things that we did,
was that,
because this technique is just
doing batch processes, right?
Just to give you the programs
and run all the test cases and
then need to give you a rank
without actually asking for
any feedback from
the developers.
Well, we found that
there is a simple way
to incorporate the feedback.
Which means when the developers
are reading these statements
from top to bottom, so
sometimes he may be sure that
this statement is clean or
he may be sure that this
statement is buggy.
Then we can incorporate that
feedback into the photo edition
process, and then improve
the photolization accuracy.
But that is not my
main point here,
so, That was the recent yeah,
because this research area was
a very hot research area, but
sometimes later people have
realized that these techniques,
it's actually not yet
practical for real world usage.
So after I actually spent one
year doing research trying to
improve the performance of this
kind of system on benchmarks for
medium size application size,
I finally tried to to make it
work on large applications.
Like Firefox, which contains
millions of lines of code.
Then I realized this technique
is actually not practical yet.
Because for one of the reasoning
is that when you are applying
this techniques to Firefox,
if there are 1 million lines of
code, and if the buggy code
is ranked in the top 1%,
then then the developer
still has to inspect tens
of thousands of lines of code,
which is actually not practical.
And also people have
learned over time or
either do an empirical study
to find out that oftentimes,
when you show a buggy line to
a developer without giving them
any logical explanation,
then they just get confused.
And then they may just miss
that bug, even if you actually
always show the bug in the top
result, in the ranking result.
And another bigger issue that
people have found over time is
that false positives can lead to
very radical interest drop-off.
If the developer inspects
the top five results and
They still can't find
any of the bugs.
And then we just fall back to
the old way of doing things,
like setting a breakpoint and
do manual debugging,
stuff like that.
And let's just generalize
a little bit to choose some of
the challenges for applying
machine learning to program
languages often during problems.
And so
one of the bigger challenges for
that area is that usually when
you try to use machine learning
to predict something in a
software engineering project, so
usually this problem actually
requires very high accuracy.
Because in that area there
are often an alternative exists.
Like for the photo audition, a
developer can always use manual
debugging or there are always
other kinds of things that they
can do to find the bug.
And if the accuracy is not high
enough, then people would just
get boring or
they will just get disappointed.
Then they will just fall back to
their old way of doing things.
And also, on this kind of, if we
try to use machine learning to
generate something from,
or software during, or
predict something for
the software during project.
Usually, it's actually
project-specific,
like I want to predict something
just for that project.
Or unless that's a very large,
open-source project, or that's
a very large commercial project
that involves a lot of the human
interactions, there won't be
a lot of labor data available
for machine learning.
So that's another bigger issue.
So another issue is that
unless the machine learning
model is fully automated and
its accuracy is very high,
the entire process always have
to involve humans in the loop.
Which means that when it
generates some results, it has
to ask the humans to inspect the
result, and then ask the humans
to incorporate the results
into the real world product.
And so if the machine learning
project can not give like logic
explanation or make
the results understandable to
the developers,
then may be very hard to
apply to the kind of technology
like to real world production.
So maintain ability is like also
another bigger issue even for
program synthesis I believe.
If you generate a piece of code
and if it's too hard to read and
developer can not
understand that,
when there's a bug it
will be very hard to fix.
So this is my last
slide summarizing
some of the future interests.
So, I'm mostly interested
in users working on
JavaScript Toolchain Support.
Or using all kinds of techniques
to improve the reliability,
performance, and
security of software systems.
And also software systems
definitely including,
is definitely including
machine learning systems.
I'm also very interested in
making this dynamic analysis
research offering a little
bit more sophisticated.
Because oftentimes we see a very
high run-time overhead in
the instrumentation techniques.
So if we can just integrate this
instrumentation framework for
directly into the engine,
it will hopefully achieve better
performance and could reduce
the run-time overhead.
So another thing that I'm
very interested in is program
synthesis.
I guess, program synthesis, so
essentially, in the original
way, developer are writing
software by themselves.
That's, in machine
learning people's terms,
that's like an expert system,
right?
You give the specification
either in terms of a formal
specification, or
you give specification in terms
of input/output examples.
Then the experts are just
the customers and developers.
Then based on those
input/outputs,
then they just develop
expert system that
use a rule-based system to
map the input to the output.
But right now it's interesting
to see that the program
synthesis can just search for
programs and generates output.
And I'm actually most
interested in speeding up
the searching process to
reduce the searching time,
because I feel that scalability
could be a bigger issue for
program synthesis field.
Because the larger the program
you want to synthesis or
more expressive the language
you are trying to use,
then it seems that the search
space will be much larger.
So it will be interesting
to use some heuristics or
some other techniques
to reduce the searching
space to further
speed up the process.
And finally, I want to thank
some of my collaborators either
in Microsoft Research or
in Berkeley and
other organizations.
So, and I also want to thank
the following organizations and
institutes for
funding my research.
So, yeah, that's it,
thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]